[Applaudissements]
bien mais mes chers amis bienvenue à
lyon et dans le rhône
tout d'abord je tiens à saluer
chaleureusement mon ami et secrétaire
départemental patrice verchère
merci à toi patrice car ensemble
je sais que depuis quelques mois nous
faisons beaucoup de travail ensemble
dans cette fédération et je suis
extrêmement fier de pouvoir travailler à
tes côtés
ce conseil national il n'aurait
également pas été possible sans les
militants qui s'investissent sans
compter et sans rien attendre en retour
merci à eux
enfin je voudrais remercier notre
président laurent wauquiez pour son
choix judicieux organiser notre conseil
national dans ce que nous pouvons
appeler le berceau de la macro ni qui on
montre aujourd'hui toutes les limites et
où notre mouvement développe des
solutions efficaces pour sortir de ces
sables mouvants incolore inodore et sans
saveur est une merveilleuse idée
parmi les solutions efficaces que nous
avons développée depuis que laurent est
à la tête de notre mouvement il y a deux
formules qui selon moi sont nous
permettent d'être sur la bonne voie la
première c'est la recherche de nos
valeurs celles d'une droite républicaine
qui s'assume et qui n'a pas peur d'être
ce qu'elle est et la deuxième essai
européenne le montre c'est la volonté de
renouvellement
et quel meilleur exemple que ce
département du rhône que cette métropole
de lyon où ce sont de nouveaux élus qui
en 2014 ont gagné des communes difficile
réputée ingagnable des villes de
banlieue et populaire et qui je sais les
conserveront l'année prochaine parce
qu'ils ont su défendre les valeurs de
droite et les faire vivre sur le terrain
à ce titre notre famille politique dans
cette fédération
comme cela est fait pour ces européennes
met en avant la transmission la
transmission voici une belle valeur de
droite à droite de nous savons
dépositaire nous ne faisons pas table
rase du passé
nous savons que l'homme n'est pas
historique ou hagiographiques nous
savons que nous sommes le fruit d'une
terre d'un arc d'une histoire d'un arbre
enracinée dans la terre de france en
tant qu légataire nous savons également
qu'un jour nous devrons transmettre à
notre tour nous savons que nous sommes
redevables envers ceux qui nous ont
précédés que nous sommes responsables de
ce qui nous succèderont à droite on ne
fait pas de guerre de génération
et c'est au nom de cette transmission de
cette belle valeur que je tiens à
profiter de ce conseil national pour
rendre hommage aux deux personnes qui
nous ont transmis cette belle fédération
du rhône et qui ont permis dans ce
territoire de faire émerger une nouvelle
génération
je tiens que vous fassiez un triomphe à
philippe cochet et michel forissier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par ailleurs je crois que nous pouvons
le dire notre liste pour les européennes
reflète exactement ce que nous sommes un
parti de droite qui a des idées qui
cesse renouvelé françois-xavier bel ami
et moi sommes de la même génération et
je le connais principalement par ses
écrits qui désolait son brillant sur
françois xavier
toute personne qui s'intéresse à
l'éducation devrait avoir lu les
déshérités et croyez-moi quand on doit
gérer des milliers d'élèves dans une
commune parfois difficiles à voir dans
sa famille politique
quelqu'un qui sait mettre des mots sur
ce que nous vivons au quotidien c'est
une véritable chance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien voici une droite qui change une
droite qui fait le pari de
l'intelligence du renouveau et de la
jeunesse
françois-xavier tué un des nouveaux
visages de cette droite qui ne détourne
pas les yeux quand elle regarde son
reflet dans le miroir des valeurs et de
l'identité avec toi comme avec agnès et
arnaud la droite elle ne se réinvente
pas elle se ressource
car ne nous méprenons pas si nous avons
reconquis des territoires souvent
réputés difficiles voire ingagnable
c'était le cas en 2014
c'est souvent parce que la droite avait
fait le choix du renouveau et de
l'audace si comme je le pressens nous
créons la surprise aux européennes c'est
parce que nous aurons fait la part belle
au renouvellement tout en s'appuyant
bien sûr sur ce qui nous nourrissent au
quotidien de leur expérience sur michel
c'est aussi parce que nous assumons ce
que nous sommes nous assumons d'être un
mouvement qui défend ses valeurs
un mouvement qui n'a pas de pas peur de
laisser s'exprimer ses membres et un
mouvement qui n'a pas peur de la bien
pensante
alors oui notre famille politique et son
président laurent wauquiez font l'objet
d'une attention médiatique
allez disons le très particulière mais
depuis le général de gaulle jusqu'à
nicolas sarkozy en passant par jacques
chirac
quel patron de notre famille politique
n'a pas eu à subir les procès en
moralité du camp exclusif du bien du
camp de l'inquisition morale de toute
manière nous ne serons jamais assez bien
pour eux de toute manière nos
compromission ne suffiront jamais les
satisfaire
la droite elle se renouvelle quand elle
ose quand elle ne s'excuse pas d'exister
et nous devons aider laurent wauquiez a
créé cette droite audacieuse et moderne
[Applaudissements]
ce renouveau il passera également par
les territoires par la france du réel où
la droite puisera ses ressources dans
l'expérience et la créativité qu'elle a
su mettre en oeuvre au contact du
quotidien des français
dans ces communes et dans ces régions
ici à lyon et dans sa métropole nous
aurons en 2020 l'occasion de mettre fin
au règne sans partage de gérard collomb
nous aurons l'occasion de faire tomber
ce pionnier du nouveau monde qui a tant
inspiré manuel macron depuis son retour
en catastrophe de la place beauvau
gérard collomb ne fait plus consensus
place de la comédie
celui que les lyonnais de tous bords
considéré à tort ou à raison comme un
grand mère qui savait brillamment
réaliser les projets de ses
prédécesseurs sem désormais la discorde
maintenant un système à force de coups
tordus et de tractations avec le système
collomb lyon est passé de la capitale de
la soie à la capitale de l'entre- soi et
en fait elle était facile celle là
mais en fait comme à paris le nouveau
monde n'est que le paravent qui sert à
dissimuler le pire de l'ancien et nous
sommes meilleurs amis et j'en terminerai
par là à lens 0-2 la reconquête de nos
territoires et à lyon avec notre
candidat etienne blanc qu'on peut
applaudir avec les maires avec les élus
ne vont partir à la reconquête de cette
métropole et nous ferons de ses
victoires à lyon et à la métropole
les symboles de la reconquête alors je
le redis aujourd'hui mes chers amis
bienvenue à lyon bienvenue dans cette
métropole de lyon terre où la droite ne
s'interdit rien terre où la droite se
renouvelle et se met en ordre de
bataille
cette bataille mes chers amis c'est une
reconquête la reconquête
c'est pour la grandeur nos deux pays
c'est pour la prospérité de nos
territoires
c'est pour la grandeur de la france en
europe vive la république vive les
républicains et bon conseil national à
tous
[Applaudissements]